hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
the cardinal virtue of courage is
something that turns out to be
incredibly important for Plato's account
of the human soul and platonic ethics
and politics in general as he's
discussing it in Republic Book for now
he does also address this this
particular disposition or virtue in
other places most notably in the Phaedo
in the LA case which is devoted entirely
to unpacking what courage is and in a
few other places but we here are gonna
concentrate just on what's going on in
Republic look for what Plato has to say
about it there it's quite interesting
and it's it's actually quite helpful not
only for understanding Plato and quite
possibly ourselves if Plato is right but
also for understanding how this virtue
is understood in other virtue ethics
that are non platonic throughout history
because they're taking their cues in
part from this treatment which seems to
be eminently Socratic in that Socrates
tends to view the virtues the moral
dispositions that are good and needed
for us human beings in order to do good
actions he tends to view them in terms
of not just habits not just the actions
that are being produced but something
cognitive as well and so we're going to
get to that in just a moment so we start
by looking at what Plato has to say
about where we should find courage now
let's remind ourselves that in Republic
book 4 Socrates has been elaborating
this ideal city why is he doing that not
for the purpose of actually saying we're
gonna create a city like this on earth
but so that we can analyze analyze from
this city to human souls because we
ourselves are kind of like the city in
that we have a similar structure so what
is the part of the soul that is going to
need courage and what is the part of the
city that's going to need courage well
if we look at the city
it's the parts that
deal with danger that have to persevere
in the face of resistance of their own
temptations to not stand up and do
things it could be fighting on the
battlefield which must have been a very
scary proposition
you know lining up with a whole bunch of
other guys with these heavy shields not
entirely covered in your body never
knowing if the spear thrust is going to
gut you and you know you'll die of
infection or the thrust itself and bleed
out and you got to stand there and hold
your ground and jab other people with
spears in the middle of dust and
shouting and blood and guts everywhere
that's pretty scary we ought we might
also think about sailors who in the
midst of a storm have to secure vital
equipment on the deck and getting up
there on the deck knowing they could be
swept off by a wave and drown in the you
know sea which was a bad thing for
Greeks
ancient Greeks maybe not so much in
Plato's time but before that tend to
think that if you died at sea or your
ghost was not gonna be happy with that
compared to burial so the part of the
city that has to deal with this that has
to cultivate courage is the part that
has to brave dangers if we want to do a
little pun there in the word brave right
what about the human soul well it's the
part of us that Plato calls sumos this
middle part located between the rational
part upon high which corresponds to the
Guardians and the appetites down below
which correspond to the ordinary people
there's this middle part with which we
get worked up or riled up the Greek term
for that that Plato uses in the Republic
is actually just a verb made out of the
noun through most through molds Ain and
it's sometimes translated as the you
know the part that with which we get
angry but it's really broader than that
it's also the part with which we for
example when we're you know lifting
weights and we get to the end of the set
and we're tempted to not do the final
repetitions it's the part with which we
push through
persevere the part with which we make
ourselves stand up against other things
perhaps outside and perhaps also within
so let's look at what Plato uses as sort
of a definition of courage I've got it
here in the Greek which literally will
be Greek to you in the sense of being
incomprehensible but we'll go through
and explain what each of the terms mean
but it's kind of good to look at this
given how the translation sometimes
meander a little bit from it so in the
Greek it Stowe anakena a hain koun amine
toy out tain Haidee upon tous olsen sews
a tone parrot on des known ducks on and
there we go forgot a diacritical mark
there what does all of this mean so I'll
give you one standard translation of
this he says here we go bravery belongs
to a city by virtue of a part of itself
owing here we go to its possession in
that part of a quality that under all
conditions will preserve the conviction
that things to be feared are precisely
those which and such the lawgiver uncle
inculcated in their education now I
didn't that's not all of the greek
phrase corresponding to that the english
went on a little bit longer there but
all of those parts are important so it's
something in a person in a human being
and we could call it a quality if we
want but he actually calls it you know
this this this thing within us that that
allows us to retain that it's this you
might say power this capacity
disposition would also be a way of
translating it quality works right
although the quality may be sounds a
little bit less forceful and it allows
us to preserve something and that's
where this so say
that's a word that we get so tore Savior
from right and a little bit later he
uses similar language to preserve to
keep to maintain to guard all of those
are ways of translating it allows us to
preserve within ourself in all
conditions the upon toast tone patter
eat owned a known doke son this is
really the most important core of it the
actually tain doak's on right the doxa
is a belief can also be translated as
opinion can also be translated as it is
in some translations conviction and it's
not the same thing as a piece de may
knowledge or wisdom Sophia it's kind of
lower on the Platonic scale of you know
access to the the true the real but it's
still good in this case and it's about
what it's about what is fearful that is
what is fear producing knowing what
really is to be feared and what is not
to be feared let's pause for a moment
and think about some of the things that
people are afraid of that really don't
bear fearing and you can say well you
know everybody's got their emotions and
emotions aren't right and wrong from a
platonic perspective and from virtue
ethics perspectives some emotional
reactions are indeed wrong if I see is
there to use an example from Aristotle
if I see a tiny mouse which can't hurt
me in any way and I recoil from it as if
it's you know a venomous snake or
something like that that's not a right
reaction that's not something to be
feared like that you know you get the
broom and push it out of the door if you
don't like it being there right or put a
bucket over it and get it out you know
set a mousetrap whatever you're gonna do
similarly there are some things that we
really should be afraid of you know if
you're going up on deck in the middle of
a hurricane to secure things you should
actually think that's scary if that
doesn't mean that you can't do your duty
if you're the Sailor who unfortunately
has to do that but it is scary right so
these you know courage allows us to
retain a right conviction about what
things are and then to respond
proportionately to respond in the way
that we ought to and where does it get
this this knowledge from this conviction
well Plato talks about three different
things in the formula that I just read
you there he talks about the law giver
right the person who is literally laying
the laws in place the law itself can be
what we want to follow law or rule and
then later on when we're talking about
the faculties of the human soul what
does courage need to obey reason the
rational faculty tells it what it ought
to fear and then it sticks with them now
it is a conviction or a belief as we
said let's talk about this in all
conditions this is where it gets really
interesting so Plato says that in all
conditions includes it's not a
comprehensive list dealing with pains or
pleasures or desires or fears so courage
isn't just about dealing with fear it's
also about dealing with fear in the face
of other things desire we could have
desire to enjoy something and the fear
of not being able to get in on it right
well we nowadays call FOMO fear of
missing out fear of missing out is
really a fear of not getting what it is
that you desire that you didn't realize
you desired until you saw somebody else
enjoying it hate pains and pleasures
these can steer us in so many different
ways he says that the brave person
preserves preserves this this
understanding of what's fearful in both
pains and pleasures desires and fears
not expel it from the soul they don't
allow that conviction to be overturned
by all these effective elements they
don't make an exception and say well in
this case no they stick to the rule that
has been given to them by some reliable
source Plato has a really interesting
analogy here that he provides for us and
this refers back a bit to book three and
also to book two he talks about this
dyeing fabrics something that most of us
are not all that familiar with if any of
you have ever experimented with tie
dyeing you know those packages that you
could buy at the grocery store and and
you know play around with white shirts
or sheets or whatever it is that you did
you know that's some of the time if you
don't really dye it well or you didn't
think through the fabric that you're
using it'd be fades away so what about
this conviction this conviction is like
the dye he says he says when dyers want
to dye wool so as to hold the purple dye
now purple is a very expensive one so
you got to make sure that it's going to
stick selecting from the many colors
there be the one nature of the white
they don't just die anything they take
white clothes and then they give it a
careful preparatory treatment so it will
take the hue in the best way and then
after the treatment and then only dip it
in the dye and he says things that are
dyed by this process become fast colored
and washing either with or without lies
cannot take away the sheen of their hues
but otherwise you know what happens they
fade so in this case what is the
preparation it is the training that's
going on then all this stuff about
gymnastics and music all of that wasn't
done for its own sake all of that was to
make it possible for the soul to be dyed
that is habituated to this conviction of
courage that would allow it to act
reliably in fearful circumstances and
not to think the things that aren't
fearful are fearful and not to act
rashly in the face of things that
we do require us to be a little bit more
cautious that dyeing itself is the right
leaf fixing the belief in the mind and
then the dyed garment would be the
courageous person the person who can be
relied upon to brave dangers either for
the sake of the city or if we're talking
about the individual person for themself
or for those closely connected with them
in circumstances where they need to act
against their own fears their potential
fears and in the face of danger so this
is what courage consists in for Plato
you